[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Die Erdbeerzeit ist
für mich die schönste Zeit im Jahr!
Denn da kann man richtig tolle Erdbeertorten backen.
Heute gibt es eine geniale Erdbeertorte!
In der Vergangenheit habe ich auch schon viele tolle gemacht.
Die könnt ihr in meiner App nachschauen oder auf dem Blog
oder
in den Backbüchern.
Jedenfalls gibt es heute eine Erdbeertorte
mit einem Schoko-Tonka-Boden.
Und ich fange jetzt erst mal mit dem Boden an
und zeige euch die Zutaten.
Ja.
Ich nehme dafür vier Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker, eine Prise Salz und etwas Tonka Wonka,
jeweils 200 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch
oder Ayran könnt ihr hier auch nehmen,
130 Gramm Mandeln, die werden gleich gemahlen,
260 Gramm Mehl, zwei Teelöffel Backpulver
und 40 Gramm Kakao.
Die Eier sind schon zimmerwarm.
Die kommen jetzt in eine Rührschüssel.
Entweder nehmt ihr jetzt ein Handrührgerät
oder so wie ich eine Küchenmaschine.
Dann Salz und Zucker dazu.
Ein bisschen Tonka Wonka.
Statt Tonka Wonka könnt ihr auch Tonkabohne dazu reiben,
einfach eine kleine Prise.
So kann man es aber auch perfekt dosieren.
Also
so, wie ihr möchtet.
Gebt nur nie zu viel Tonkabohnenabrieb hinzu!
Denn Tonkabohne ist wie Muskatnuss.
Wenn man zu viel davon nimmt,
wirkt es eben auch giftig.
Aber eine kleine Prise reicht auch schon,
weil es superergiebig ist.
Und jetzt die Eier-Zucker-Masse
für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten cremig rühren.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Mandeln mahlen.
Und, worauf ich auch immer achte,
gerade bei so Rührteigen,
also die Eier sind zimmerwarm.
Und hier habe ich Ayran
statt Buttermilch,
weil es einfach offen war.
Könnt ihr auch immer super nehmen.
Und der Ayran ist auch schon warm.
Den habe ich in die Mikrowelle gestellt.
Also immer alle Zutaten schön die gleiche Temperatur.
[Musik]
Die Eier-Zucker-Masse ist jetzt schon soweit.
Ich werde jetzt hier schon mal meinen Tortenring einschlagen
in Backpapier,
weil der Teig einfach sehr flüssig ist.
Den habe ich schon auf 24cm eingestellt.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier schon beide Flüssigkeiten dazu geben.
Also Öl, da nehme ich immer gerne Sonnenblumenöl
oder Maiskeimöl
oder ihr könnt auch Rapsöl nehmen,
wobei Rapsöl, finde ich, beim Erhitzen etwas fischig riecht
durch die Omega-3- und -6-Fettsäuren.
Also für mich riecht es echt mega nach Fisch.
Dann den Ayran oder die Buttermilch dazu geben.
Kurz einrühren.
Und jetzt kann ich hier
schon mal die trockenen Zutaten vermischen.
Also einfach zu den Mandeln das Mehl dazu geben,
Backpulver
und Kakao.
Und mit dem Schneebesen verrühren.
Und das kommt jetzt direkt zu den flüssigen Zutaten
und wird nur noch kurz eingerührt.
Also hier jetzt nicht mehr lange rühren,
sondern wirklich nur noch kurz,
damit der Kuchen nicht speckig wird.
Wobei neulich jemand geschrieben hat:
"Ich mag speckigen Kuchen."
Da habe ich gesagt: "Gut. Dann rühr halt weiter.
Dann rühr halt noch mehr."
Also ich mache meist vorher dann schon die Maschine aus
und rühre dann einfach noch ganz kurz
so mit dem Schneebesen durch,
damit es wirklich nicht überrührt wird.
So. Das reicht dann schon.
[Musik]
Normalerweise nicht klopfen an den Rand.
Denn ihr wollt ja nicht die Luft, die ihr eingerührt habt,
wieder rausklopfen.
Okay.
Jetzt fülle ich die Masse schon mal hier rein,
kann den Kuchen gleich backen
und dann kommt schon die Erdbeercreme dran.
[Musik]
Hier am Rand immer gerne ein bisschen hochstreichen.
Und sofort backen.
[Musik]
Während der Kuchen noch im Ofen backt,
kann ich schon mal die Erdbeercreme zubereiten
und vorbereiten.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt auch gefrorene Erdbeeren,
weil ich
die einfach noch da hatte.
Und die frischen Erdbeeren nehme ich dann
für die Dekoration und zum Reinschneiden.
Die gefrorenen werden nämlich gleich zerkleinert
und dadurch entsteht die Erdbeercreme.
Aber da könnt ihr statt gefrorenen Erdbeeren
gerne auch die frischen nehmen,
wenn sie schön reif sind.
Okay.
Also für die Creme brauche ich
400 Gramm gefrorene oder frische Erdbeeren,
500 Gramm Frischkäse in Doppelrahmstufe,
100 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
500 Gramm Sahne,
San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und noch Erdbeeren zum Kleinschneiden.
Die Erdbeeren habe ich bereits auftauen lassen.
Die werden jetzt kurz püriert.
Also egal, ob jetzt gefrorene oder frische Erdbeeren,
einfach kurz pürieren.
[Musik]
Dann kommt das Ganze direkt in einen Topf.
Und hier kann ich jetzt das Erdbeerpüree einkochen lassen.
So intensiviert sich nämlich der Geschmack
und ich werde einfach das Wasser in den Erdbeeren los
sozusagen.
Das lassen wir jetzt aufkochen.
Und dann leicht köcheln lassen.
Das Erdbeerpüree dann so lange einkochen,
bis die Feuchtigkeit fast komplett verkocht ist.
Also schön jetzt alles vorbereiten
und später kann man dann alles gut zusammenfügen.
Dann kann ich jetzt hier
den Frischkäse
reingeben.
Dann Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Puderzucker dazu.
Und dann kann ich hier
den Frischkäse schon mal schön verrühren.
Einfach kurz cremig rühren.
[Musik]
Das war es erst mal.
Ich stelle jetzt einfach kurz alle Zutaten,
also die Sahne und vor allem die Quarkcreme,
in den Kühlschrank
und warte, wie gesagt, einfach kurz auf die Erdbeeren.
[Musik]
Die Erdbeeren sind jetzt wunderbar eingekocht.
Also es ist fast keine Flüssigkeit mehr da.
Es ist eine richtig dicke Paste jetzt geworden,
also ein dickes Püree.
Das fülle ich jetzt hier noch mal um,
damit es schön abkühlen kann.
Denn, bevor das nicht kalt ist, kann ich nicht weitermachen.
Also hier jetzt umfüllen,
richtig kühlschrankkalt abkühlen lassen.
Ich lasse es natürlich
vorher auf Zimmertemperatur erst mal kommen,
stelle es dann in den Kühlschrank
und dann geht es gleich weiter.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist
das Erdbeerpüree schön kalt.
Und ich kann es jetzt hier direkt zum Quark dazu geben.
>> AYLIN: Frischkäse!
>> SALLY: Zum Frischkäse dazu geben.
Ja.
Ich wollte ursprünglich eine Quarkcreme machen
und dann habe ich mich doch dazu entschlossen,
eine Frischkäsecreme zu machen.
Jetzt habe ich ständig Quark im Kopf.
Hast du auch ständig Quark im Kopf?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich bin heute irgendwie neben der Spur.
[Musik]
Da kommt jetzt San-apart dazu.
Jetzt kurz verrühren.
Man nimmt immer einen Teelöffel San-apart
pro 100 Milliliter oder 100 Gramm Masse.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach
für die Erdbeeren noch mal zwei Teelöffel dazu,
also zusätzlich zum Quark.
Okay.
Jetzt rühre ich hier langsam die Sahne ein.
Und da immer darauf achten...
Was?
>> AYLIN: Das ist immer noch Frischkäse!
>> SALLY: Das ist immer noch Frischkäse.
O Mann!
Jetzt rühre ich hier langsam die Sahne ein.
Und da immer darauf achten,
dass sie schön kalt ist.
[Musik]
Und jetzt noch mal San-apart rein
und richtig schön steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Die Creme kommt jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Und jetzt könnt ihr die Erdbeeren entweder vierteln
oder achteln oder auch in Würfel schneiden.
Ich glaube, ich achtel die jetzt kurz.
Dann sind sie nämlich feiner.
Ja.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich jetzt als Nächstes den Tortenboden rauslösen.
Der ist jetzt auch schön kalt.
Den hatte ich jetzt auch ganz kurz noch im Kühlschrank,
damit er sich besser schneiden lässt.
[Musik]
Jetzt stürzen und das Backpapier abziehen.
Und ich werde ihn jetzt
zweimal durchschneiden.
Dann habe ich drei Böden.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Torte füllen.
Und da nehme ich meist den Tortendeckel einfach umgedreht,
damit ich später den geraden Boden als Deckel habe,
also die glatte Fläche habe.
Und ich arbeite jetzt auch gleich
mit einem Tortenring direkt außen herum.
Perfekt!
Dann kommt jetzt hier etwas Creme rein.
Die wird glatt verstrichen.
[Musik]
Darauf gebe ich jetzt die Hälfte der Erdbeeren.
Ein bisschen Creme zum Abdecken.
Wenn ihr möchtet,
dass die Torte auch noch zwei, drei Tage frisch ist,
dann macht lieber eine Fruchteinlage
statt frischen Erdbeeren hier rein.
Also dann kocht die Erdbeeren ein,
macht eine Fruchteinlage.
Denn diese Erdbeeren wären jetzt morgen,
spätestens übermorgen werden die matschig.
Und mit Fruchteinlagen habt ihr sie einfach noch länger frisch.
Aber, da wir die jetzt sowieso sofort verzehren werden,
nehme ich frische Erdbeeren.
Jetzt den mittleren Boden rein.
Dann das gleiche Spiel,
also etwas Creme, die restlichen Erdbeeren
und dann den Deckel drauf.
[Musik]
Und hier beim Füllen immer darauf achten,
dass ihr die Creme so glatt wie möglich streicht.
Das heißt, hier jetzt keinen Hubbel bilden.
Ansonsten hat die Torte später auch einen Hubbel.
Also ich gucke dann schon,
dass ich die Erdbeeren
so ein bisschen reindrücke in die Creme.
Und dann gleicht sich das nämlich richtig schön aus.
Jetzt den Deckel darauf geben.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehme ich einfach einen Tortenretter zum Abdecken.
So bekommt sie keine schlechten Gerüche im Kühlschrank.
Die übrige Creme, die packe ich jetzt auch noch ab.
Und jetzt kommt die Torte
für mindestens drei Stunden in den Kühlschrank
und dann können wir sie weiter dekorieren.
Hier noch die Krümelchen weg.
Fertig!
Gestern wurde es mir tatsächlich zu spät
und ich habe die Torte nicht mehr fertig gemacht.
Heute stelle ich sie aber fertig.
Wie gesagt, war die jetzt über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
Die Creme war auch über Nacht im Kühlschrank.
Beides schön abgedeckt.
Und jetzt kann ich die Torte fertig dekorieren.
Erst mal löse ich sie hier raus.
Wir haben gestern einfach noch so viel gegrillt
und so viel gedreht,
dass die Torte nicht mehr fertig wurde.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Dafür ist sie jetzt gut durchgekühlt.
Ta-taa!
Oh!
Erdbeertorte
gibt es heute!
Gut.
Und jetzt wird sie am Rand schön glatt gestrichen.
Ihr könnt das jetzt entweder so machen mit einer Palette,
ich zeige es euch aber auch einmal mit Ganaching Boards.
Denn damit geht es auch megaeinfach.
Aber wartet.
Zuerst
werde ich den Rand ein bisschen einstreichen,
so die erste Schicht.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehme ich hier so ein Ganaching Board,
was etwas größer ist,
das heißt 25cm im Durchmesser.
Jetzt kurz die Torte stürzen.
[Musik]
Damit es nicht rutscht.
So.
Und jetzt habe ich hier zwei Ganaching Boards
und schaue jetzt, dass die schön übereinanderliegen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kann ich hier einfach die Creme nehmen
und dazwischenstreichen.
Und dann wird sie nämlich gleich schön glatt.
Deswegen hebt auf jeden Fall genug Creme auch auf,
dass ihr den Rand schön glatt bekommt.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr jetzt den kompletten Rand eingestrichen habt,
könnt ihr eine Teigkarte nehmen oder eben die Palette
und das Ganze jetzt hier abziehen.
Und dafür ist jetzt eben das Ganaching Board praktisch,
eins oben, eins unten sozusagen als Abgrenzung.
Dann habe ich den Rand schon mal glatt.
Ich schaue noch mal, ob irgendwo was fehlt,
so wie hier ein kleines Stückchen.
[Musik]
Und dann noch mal abziehen.
Und fertig.
Ich stelle die Torte jetzt kurz in den Kühlschrank,
damit ich einfach die Creme jetzt nicht zerstöre.
Ich glaube, ich stelle es direkt mit der Tortenplatte rein.
So für etwa eine halbe Stunde.
Und kann dann noch mal
die restliche Creme in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Da wird nämlich noch die Oberfläche geglättet.
Jetzt kann ich das obere Ganaching Board wegnehmen.
Ganz vorsichtig.
Ich will den Rand nicht zerstören.
[Musik]
Gut.
Und jetzt hier noch die Oberfläche schön glätten
mit der Creme.
Ich habe übrigens noch ein bisschen Creme gemacht.
Also ich schreibe euch dann auch die veränderte Menge
in die App beziehungsweise auf den Blog.
Denn dann habt ihr auch genügend Creme zum Verstreichen.
Und jetzt hier schön von innen nach außen
mit der Palette.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt gucke ich erst mal,
dass ich die Oberfläche schön glatt bekomme.
Und dann gehe ich noch einmal an den Rand und fertig.
[Musik]
Und jetzt nehmt ihr eine kleine Palette
und streicht praktisch den Überschuss von außen nach innen.
Nun mach halt.
[Musik]
Das passt.
Da kommt ja noch Deko drauf.
Also jetzt kommt die Torte
am besten kurz ins Gefrierfach.
Und ich kann schon mal die Schokosoße herstellen.
Denn das soll eine Drip Torte werden.
Und die restliche Creme
fülle ich schon mal in einen Spritbeutel ein.
Für den Drip, also für die Schokosoße,
verwende ich jetzt Sahne,
etwas Kokosfett
und dunkle Schokolade.
Da habe ich jetzt eine Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Ich kann jetzt hier die Sahne schon mal aufkochen lassen.
Und solche Drips sind immer am einfachsten,
wenn man sie auf eine Buttercremetorte macht
oder auf eine
Ganache-Torte.
Auf einer Quarkcreme ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig.
Daher habe ich jetzt die Torte eingefroren,
damit die Quarkcreme einfach schön fest wird
und durch das Heruntertropfen der Ganache
nicht mit runterfließt.
Das ist so die Schwierigkeit bei Drip Cakes,
wollte ich euch nur mal kurz sagen.
Quit playing games with my heart.
My heart.
Wenn die Sahne kocht, dann schaltet ihr den Herd bitte aus.
Dann kommt Kokosfett rein.
Das sorgt für den schönen Glanz.
Dann die Kuvertüre.
Und jetzt einfach schön rühren.
Wunderbar!
Und die Ganache, die könnt ihr dann gleich
entweder mit einem Löffel über die Torte tröpfeln
oder mit einem Spritzbeutel
oder mit so einem kleinen Fläschchen.
Ich zeige euch das gleich mit einem Fläschchen.
Aber ich lasse sie einen ganz kurzen Moment abkühlen.
[Musik]
Wie eine Katzenmama, gell?
>> ELA: Ja.
Eigentlich wollte ich gar nicht.
Weißt du, was Katzenmamas
– Katzenbabys am besten machen?
>> SALLY: Was?
>> ELA: Mit Wollknäueln zu spielen.
>> SALLY: Mit Wollknäueln?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann machen sie so mit ihren Tatzen, nicht?
>> ELA: Nein.
Guck. So ein kleiner Ball
mit Faden.
>> SALLY: Und die stupsen sich immer die Nase so.
>> ELA: Guck. Die macht dann so.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und dann kraulen sie sich so den Rücken.
So mit ihren Tatzen.
Katzentatzen.
Und dann kitzeln sie sich.
Killekille, killekille, killekille, killekille, killekille.
>> ELA: Hühnerkacke. Hühnerkacke.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Von Katzen auf Hühnerkacke.
Psst!
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich den Drip hier in eine Flasche gefüllt.
Und am besten probiert ihr ihn...
Warte. Das macht die Mama. Okay?
Am besten probiert ihr ihn auf einer Rückseite aus,
ob er,
wenn ihr ihn darüberfließen lasst,
ob er eben dann schön fest wird
oder ob er vielleicht zu flüssig oder zu fest ist.
Also die Torte ist jetzt schön kalt.
Der Drip, der ist noch lauwarm.
Muss er ja auch.
Denn die Schokolade wird ja gleich fest.
>> ELA: Das sieht wie Eiscreme aus außen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Gleich machen wir die Erdbeeren drauf.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Die Glasur hängt bis hier drunter.
Aber das macht nichts.
>> SALLY: Ja, das macht hier nichts.
Okay.
Die gehört so, Ela.
Und zack, einen runter.
Weiter.
Und wieder, zack, einen runter.
Und zack.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Und da noch mal.
>> SALLY: Cool, nicht?
Guck mal. Das hast du gemacht.
>> ELA: Kannst du...
Mama, kannst du auch...
Mama, ich habe eine coole Idee!
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Du kannst
da, wo keine Mitte ist,
da, da kannst du
"Sallys Torte" draufschreiben.
>> SALLY: Oh.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Weil dann weiß immer jeder, dass...
>> SALLY: Glaubst du, das ist eine schöne Torte
zum Muttertag vielleicht?
>> ELA: Ja!
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: Hierhin!
>> SALLY: Und jetzt gebe ich hier
ein bisschen noch in die Mitte,
aber gar nicht so viel.
>> ELA: Wo ist die Mitte?
>> SALLY: Also hier an den Rand, nicht in die Mitte.
Danke fürs Korrigieren.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
Hallo.
Für den Geschmack wollen wir hier
auch noch ein bisschen Schokolade haben.
>> ELA: Mum! Stopp! Stopp! Stopp, Mama!
>> SALLY: Warte.
>> ELA: Wir wollen doch nicht...
>> SALLY: Ich nehme nicht alles.
Ich lasse dir was übrig. Okay?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß doch, was du willst.
Warte kurz. Ich hole mal kurz eine Palette.
Aber nicht anfassen! Ja?
>> ELA: Weißt du auch, was meine Lieblingsschokolade ist?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> ELA: Geschmolzene Schokolade natürlich!
Hast du das dir schon mal gedacht?
>> SALLY: Geschmolzene Schokolade
ist deine Lieblingsschokolade?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das habe ich mir fast gedacht. Ja.
>> ELA: Aber manchmal mag ich auch andere Schokolade.
>> SALLY: Feste Schokolade?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
Und Schokosoße auf Eis?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich nehme die mal zur Seite.
>> ELA: Ich möchte die!
>> SALLY: Die willst du dann als Eis essen?
[Musik]
>> ELA: Das ist aber ein cooles Eis!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> ELA: Da ist super Milch drinnen.
>> SALLY: Danke.
>> ELA: Zu spät.
>> SALLY: O nein!
Hast du es gerade vermischt?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> ELA: Ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Hier. Ich wollte es noch dekorieren für dich.
Ach, Ela.
Was wolltest du sagen?
>> ELA: Ich meinte also [Schmatzen].
Können wir auch mal so welches Eis machen
in einer Eiskugel?
>> SALLY: So eine Eismaschine?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir mal Erdbeereis machen zusammen?
Check.
>> ELA: Mit Schokosoße!
>> SALLY: Okay!
>> ELA: Guck, die Schokosoße!
>> SALLY: Wir machen mal Erdbeereis mit Schokosoße.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen Creme
– ich habe etwas mehr Creme gemacht –
in einen Spritzbeutel gefüllt
mit einer Rosettentülle hier vorne.
Und damit, liebe Ela, dekoriere ich jetzt die Torte.
Okay?
Also hier immer so kleine Kringel.
>> ELA: Ja. Das meinte ich auch mit der Schokosoße.
[Musik]
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich will es auch gar nicht so symmetrisch machen.
[Musik]
Und dann nehme ich noch Erdbeeren.
Die halbiere ich jetzt
und setze die noch mit drauf.
Ich glaube, ohne Grün heute.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich noch ein bisschen Rosmarin aus dem Garten
so für das essbare Grün.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama, wenn du willst,
kannst du eine ganze Erdbeere
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> ELA: in die Mitte machen.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Das wäre auch eine Idee.
Aber dann habe ich...
>> ELA: Aber dafür musst du dann die Blätter wegmachen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Aber dann habe ich ein Problem.
>> ELA: Warum?
>> SALLY: Und zwar kann ich dann die Torte
nicht mehr so schön anschneiden.
[Musik]
So.
Backen mit Kind.
Hör auf, Ela!
Das ist eklig!
Okay.
Meine Torte kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen in die Kühlung
und dann
kümmere ich mich um diese kleine Torte.
Und dann können wir die Torte probieren.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine richtig hübsche...
>> ELA: Welche?
>> SALLY: Die hier.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine richtig hübsche Muttertagstorte,
die ihr zubereiten könnt
ohne viel Schnickschnack
und trotzdem wunderschön dekoriert.
>> ELA: Was ist der Muttertag?
>> SALLY: Ich bringe sie mal vor Ela in Sicherheit.
[Musik]
Okay.
Murat, komm. Wir probieren die Muttertagstorte.
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Denn ich bin Mutter und du bist mein Mann.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Sieht cool aus.
Natürlich ein Drip Cake.
Bei Drip Cakes sagt man natürlich, da gibt es eine Regel.
Ob man sich daran halten möchte oder nicht,
das ist euch überlassen.
Der Drip darf niemals unten ankommen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Hast du gut gemacht.
>> SALLY: Und wenn doch, finde ich es auch nicht schlimm.
>> MURAT: Sieben Jahre Pech auf jeden Fall,
wenn es ankommt.
Und dann,
es sieht cool aus.
Ich mag Erdbeercreme.
Und ich glaube...
Ist es die Erdbeercreme, die du öfters machst?
Oder ist es was ganz Neues?
>> SALLY: Mit Frischkäse, eingekochten Erdbeeren.
>> MURAT: Richtig lecker!
Weil die schmeckt so richtig joghurtlastig.
Und...
>> SALLY: Ich habe es gewusst.
>> MURAT: Und das Coole ist natürlich auch hier...
Hier ist dein Tortenstück.
>> MURAT: Rosmarin passt natürlich
genial auf Torten,
gibt dem eine Optik.
Cool.
Ich probiere.
>> SALLY: Manche sagen
Rosmarin.
Manche sagen Rossmarin.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Sag mir, was du rausschmeckst.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Schokolade
>> SALLY: Hm.
und Erdbeer.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> MURAT: Joghurt.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Tonka Wonka.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Hm.
>> SALLY: Passt voll gut, nicht?
>> MURAT: Hm.
Und du hast, glaube ich, Nüsse in den Boden reingebaut.
Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Mandeln.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Voll gut, he!
Das Coole ist hier...
Coole Torte!
Zwei Sachen noch.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Dann bin ich auch weg.
Ganz genial! Macht sie nach!
Erdbeeren:
Jetzt momentan: Kauft sie saisonal.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Beim Erdbeerbauern.
>> MURAT: Beim Erdbeerbauern.
Unterstützt eure Region,
euren Bauern in eurer Nähe!
Kauft die Erdbeeren bei euren Bauern!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Die haben gerade
eine schwierige Zeit hinter sich.
Und unterstützt sie einfach.
Ganz, ganz wichtig!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Macht das bitte!
Und das Nächste ist jetzt was Persönliches.
Meine Mutter ist leider nicht da.
Die ist in der Türkei.
Und ich kann sie gerade nur anrufen,
kann sie auch nicht besuchen.
Und
ich wollte meine Mutter grüßen ganz, ganz lieb.
>> SALLY: Zum Muttertag.
>> MURAT: Zum Muttertag alles, alles Liebe!
Und ich hoffe, ich kann dich bald wieder besuchen, Mama.
Pass auf dich auf.
Und
ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Alles Liebe euch!
Einen schönen Muttertag
>> MURAT: Allen Müttern.
>> SALLY: an alle Mamas!
Seid ganz...
>> SALLY: Und an alle Papas:
Unterstützt die Mamas! Unterschätzt ihre Arbeit nicht!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Denn Mamas leisten ganz schön viel!
Alles, alles Liebe euch allen zum Muttertag!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Wirklich!
Gerade jetzt ganz, ganz wichtig!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Kinder großziehen ist nicht so einfach.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Macht es gut!
Macht es besser!
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Boah, ich liebe die
>> SALLY: Voll lecker, gell?
>> MURAT: Erdbeeren gerade so!
>> SALLY: Und ich habe die gestern gefüllt.
Aber das macht keinen Unterschied, nicht?
Merkt man gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Schmeckt echt gut.
Schön durchgezogen.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
Die besten Erdbeeren sind die heimischen Erdbeeren.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Und jetzt bringen wir Mama und Papa
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Torte, stellen es vor die Tür.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Tschüss!
Mmh!
[Musik]